[Music]
pre-covered everyone in the hospitality
industry was freaking out about
Airbnb and VRBO and this whole Shadow
industry and then it started to get more
regulated but the reality is it's just
additional Supply that's out there but
it's very different I think if people
are looking for a big house sure Airbnb
might be better but if you're a business
person if you're traveling with your
wife a lot of the
conveniences of a hotel cannot be
overlooked to the challenges of Airbnb
so there's probably short-term rental
3.0 which is basically setting up a
hotel within your collection of
short-term rentals the problem with that
is all right guys bang bang I've Got
Jake here with me uh I thought a great
place to start is you guys have a very
unique model uh to an outsider in the
real estate industry you guys buy real
estate but you also operate the
hospitality business inside of that real
estate so kind of your double dipping I
think of that as like a McDonald's
strategy right on the real estate run
the restaurant why is that the area of
real estate that you're so focused on
think that you can generate such great
returns from it so I grew up in the
hospitality business ever since I was a
little kid I was working in restaurants
when I was way too young to be dealing
with alcohol and it was a business that
my dad had when I decided to come into
our business there was three hotels and
my vision was always to grow it so the
short answer is
I fast became an expert and really
obsessed with hospitality because like
you said it combines real estate
investing with an operating business
most real estate businesses you just buy
the real estate you sign a long-term
lease and that's it maybe you do some
value-add Hospitality you have to do
that plus every single day I need to
sell a room I need to create an
experience I need to design a restaurant
I need to pick out food I need to sell
that room every single day and convince
people that this is where they need to
spend their money to create these
special moments and that is
the most exciting thing about
Hospitality it's also the biggest risk
with hospitality it is definitely the
most complicated form of real estate out
there which can lead to Great returns
but it's definitely more risky than a
triple net lease that you're just
signing yeah so I think most people who
do kind of dabble in real estate maybe
not our professionals but they own some
real estate or if they've done some real
estate investing they'd be like why
would you spend all the time banging
your head against the wall to do all of
that when you could just buy the
building triple net lease it and then
like chill and a check shows up every
single month I'm guessing it's because
you guys are like well if you're good at
it then there's this kind of outsized
return that you can generate what makes
someone good at actually operating and
when we talk about Hospitality I think
it's important to clarify you guys
really aren't running a ton of
restaurants and things it's specifically
around these hotels uh that you guys own
and operate like what makes you good at
actually operating those types of
businesses well we do do all the food
and beverage outlets in our hotels and
that's a huge differentiating Factor so
the type of hospitality that we don't
focus on is commoditized Hospitality
because if you're going to do that I
always say you might as well do
Apartments because it's there's no
secret sauce it's very commodity driven
it's expected
the returns are all kind of guaranteed
and you can really plan with Apartments
it's very similar except you just have
an annual lease what we do is highly
differentiated lifestyle properties
Boutique properties where we can really
out compete our competition because of
what we do and we do it from design we
do it from food and beverage and we do
it from the experiences that we create
on property and by the way this doesn't
have to be some super cool hotel any
hotel that we own whether it's a
Sheridan a Hilton or the Del Mar which
we have in Fort Lauderdale we try to
elevate that experience above what a
guest would typically experience if
you're talking about a Hampton Inn on
the side of the road that is pure
commodity you're basically in the real
estate business with a little sprinkle
of Hotel on it but it's not what we do
we are experts in the hard stuff and we
do it because I'm passionate about it
that's what I want to do that's where I
want to spend my time so when you are
are going into a project let's just take
it kind of from square one you're trying
to find a good location are these
usually existing hotels that you're just
taking over and kind of you're going to
Rebrand and increase the operational
efficiency and Effectiveness or are you
guys going and finding land and you're
like we're going to build a building
from scratch and we're going to do this
like what is the kind of Ideal deal that
you guys look for we do both so we do
ground up development and we find
existing buildings there's a lot less
risk with finding existing buildings but
it's also a lot more fun and the upside
potentially is greater if you go and
develop we focus on high powered entry
markets those commodity roadside type
hotels that I talked about
anyone could just build a hotel across
the street from you down the road from
you and the barriers to entry are very
low we want to focus on areas where
there's less competition because it
gives us a greater opportunity to
compete now the way that real estate is
going a lot of sites that could even be
possible for hotel development are just
getting priced to other asset classes
like office or multi-family so the
amount of hotels coming in is actually
far less than it was before but I always
say it's pretty simple we want to invest
in places that we want to go that is
typically these smile States I mean
where are the emerging neighborhoods
where are the existing hybrid entry
markets that have
the environment and the landscape that
people want to spend money that might be
a resort but it might also be a Downtown
City but it has to have that energy and
that life when you go into a hotel that
is not yours so you're on vacation
somewhere and you go into a hotel what
are the things that will either make you
say this is an amazing experience or
this is a complete [__] you know
experience like they don't care at all
are there like little tells on either
direction that you're paying attention
to I went into one two days ago and I
was like this is why we're in the hotel
business that was the experience and the
feeling that that hotel gave me so you
walk into the hotel the design was
stunning it was actually the addition
Hotel in Tampa the architecture is
beautiful there was a coffee shop all
the pastries looked high-end and stuff
that you'd want to eat the bar was laid
out well we went up to the rooftop pool
it was active the bartenders were all in
great uniforms there were flowers and
plants and great landscaping and there
were people laying out and it just is
the type of place that you're like all
right this has a Vibe this has a soul
someone cares it had a unique smell it
had a great nightclub there someone put
the care and attention the detail to
make this thing a success and that's the
whole point of why you do it otherwise
just make it an apartment that you don't
have to think about it anymore if you're
going to go through the brain damage and
the investment to do a hotel you might
as well put all the time and effort in
to make it unique and make it memorable
yeah what's interesting about this is uh
to a hotel goer which I've traveled a
ton over the years uh I am not the what
is the vibe what is whatever I've
usually been like how close is it to
where I need to be and like what is the
price so you're transactional 100
transactional but I will say that over
the years I realized there were certain
places that I went where I was like that
place is nice and it almost became this
like joke uh whether it was with close
friends or my wife where I'd be like oh
The X hotel in this city and I'm like
what I'm like listen I don't know uh I
just remember that hotel and you can't
even necessarily like pinpoint what it
was I think you just know that like
somebody cared or whatever and so then
when I found myself even though I
thought of myself as a transactional
person yep I would be like oh I have to
go to that City see if there's a room in
this place and I would actually think of
the place before I thought of the price
yeah and so it like was one of those
things where if you ask people what they
do they tell you one thing but if you
watch what they do they may actually do
something else why is that is it do we
like to think of ourselves as economic
buyers but maybe actually we kind of buy
with our heart uh and emotion sometimes
well I think post covet this has
completely changed for everyone and
people are placing a higher emphasis on
experiences and experiences don't have
to be high-end or expensive you can have
the coolest hotel that brings back some
great memory for you and it could be
like a three-star hotel or you can have
the same thing at a five-star hotel so I
think
it's like anything look at the iPhone
people appreciate good design they
appreciate well thought out aesthetic
but more importantly they want to feel
like they identify with a hotel like
staying here says something about me
maybe it says I have taste maybe it says
I know the great neighborhood to stay in
maybe it says that I am a big foodie and
I like the food and I like the bar at
this hotel so I think people want to
identify with that the second thing is
when you're traveling for work your
primary focus is work now people are
starting to travel for work and
combining that with vacation so you're
saying hey I'm going to bring my wife or
say hey I'm going to stay for two days
my wife's going to come for the next two
days and we're going to hang out for the
weekend and that becomes the moment in
the experience that you're looking for
versus what was just before was like Hey
I want like a clean room and like a
decent shower and coffee in the morning
and I'm out
when you look at a deal walk me through
like the economics one of these things
right so um I don't know what kind of
like a down the Fairway deal for you
guys would be but like let's say that
you are going to take over an existing
building so you're going to purchase the
building and then you're going to put a
complete Rebrand of the hotel into it
how much money does that cost for you
guys to actually kind of get started and
get to just opening day if you will um
and then what does it look like to
actually run one of these things and how
do you think about the potential
investment returns for uh investors
including are there separate investors
for the real estate in the operating
business like just kind of walk me
through one of these deals yeah so I'll
give you two really good recent examples
we bought a hotel a couple months ago in
Boca Raton Florida so pretty close close
to where we're filming this and I think
we paid 40 million dollars for the hotel
and we're probably going to put five or
six million dollars into it the reason
why we love that deal is it's an
incredibly High borrowed entry market
and all of the money we're going to
spend is going towards guest facing
return on investment items so if we want
to look at doing adding a bar we're
going to say how much extra Revenue will
this bar generate or what impact will
that have on the overall guest
experience to justify whether to do it
take another deal that we did where we
bought a hotel in just outside of DC
great deal the hotel was ripping before
covid we undertook a massive renovation
we probably spent on that hotel
30 million dollars and we bought it for
30 million dollars so a huge amount of
investment the negative to that deal
which maybe will pay off down the road
when someone else buys it from us is
that probably half of that spend was
Behind the Walls replacing Windows
replacing a new skin on the building
and the other half was front-facing so
the key is to really identify those
buildings that have great bones that the
money that you spend is going to impact
the guests and you're going to get a
return on that investment and the way
that we Finance these deals is with debt
and we raise money from institutional
Partners or high net worth investors and
they come in and typically we're
shooting for mid to high teens irrs and
I think a great deal would be 20 irr
with a multiple of money so maybe we
hold that for five years and you'll
double your money or if we hold it for a
little bit longer maybe it'll triple
your money so those are kind of the
economics that we look for but when we
invest in these deals we are always
going in saying how can we improve it
not only by upgrading the management
which is again unique to us because
we're vertically integrated so how do we
upgrade how they're spending money how
they're charging for the rooms what
their expenses are but also how do we
upgrade the physical product which goes
back to the real estate side so how do
we renovate the rooms how do we make a
better bar how how do we make a better
guest arrival experience and one of the
cheapest ways to do that frankly is with
Landscaping so a big priority for us is
always to go in and hit the Landscaping
if we're in Florida to make sure the
pool is great to make sure there's an
outdoor bar because that's what people
want
and these preferences have really
changed so a lot of these older hotels
you're stuck with things that you're
never gonna use or need so part of the
challenge is figuring out
where guest Trends will be for the next
five to ten to 20 years and repurpose
some of these older hotels to do that
there's certainly a lot of upside to
doing that but you can also build new
and design it exactly how you want what
are some of the trends that you guys
think are changing like what were people
doing that they may not be doing and
what do you think people will be doing
in the future people have placed a huge
emphasis on really inspired food and
beverage so I think every great hotel
has to have a coffee shop right by the
front door people want to go they don't
want to go to Starbucks by the way
anymore it's like that's feeling too
commodity they want to go to kind of
this hipster Brew spot and get their
coffee I think a rooftop bar is also
critical to create that life and the
other side of that is more of a compact
food and beverage so if you're going to
have meetings
does it need to be these huge massive
ballrooms if you're outside of a big
major Metro like Vegas or Miami probably
not maybe it's cooler more creative type
meeting spaces one thing that we're also
starting to do is put in podcasts or
Zoom rooms
so if you're a podcaster and you're
traveling you want to still be able to
execute your podcast and how many zooms
have you been on where someone's like in
their hotel room and you see their messy
bed in their background like it's a joke
so building these things is definitely a
way of the Future Fitness is another
huge thing that we prioritize and then
like the offshoots of that so maybe a
golf simulator so that is one of the
things that you can put in you know if
one of these big hotels have so many
extra meeting space put a golf simulator
in one maybe put a children's arcade in
another and you enlarge the fitness
center that would be really uh another
big priority that we focus on and then
another trend is I think people are
going to be less reliant on Brands and
more focused on the hotel that
identifies with them so they're going to
probably start to shy away from Marriott
and Hilton as a name which to combat
that those big companies are creating
what's called a soft brand so you're
still getting their reservation system
you're still getting that power but
they're letting you call the hotel
whatever you want and that is going to
be like a white label solution where 100
of the infrastructure but you can call
the brand whatever you want and exactly
they see they'll get the data as to
what's working what's not working and
they can kind of move
um what I think is fascinating is this
idea of like what are people doing in
the hotel rooms right so podcasting is
one thing
um also I've never really understood why
uh inside of a hotel there seems to be
like sometimes really big hotels like
two floors nobody's using except for
like the big conference right and when
you walk by them it's always weird
because like sometimes some people sneak
in there to do a call or or do whatever
how do you think about actual like
dedicated space or golf simulator you're
not like rolling in and rolling out
right it's like you're pretty much
putting it there it's static it's fixed
um have hotels started to do anything
with like Dynamic type spaces where you
could basically say hey there's a
children's arcade right now but if
there's a big conference and we can
actually make more money like you almost
get into like a dynamic pricing for the
space that is not for the actual uh
Hotel guests or is that just too
complicated logistically and so it's
better just to kind of go in with a a
thesis in terms of what the trends will
be and stick to those they were trying
to do a lot of that pre-cover they're
all these little startups that were kind
of like renting rooms by the hour during
off times or allowing you to check in
later and you could use an app and use
these rooms for little meeting areas if
you had a longer flight but I think all
that's really just BS I mean the reality
is you have to design and build better
spaces so they're not being wasted or
you have to incentivize your sales team
to really go sell those spaces so
they're generating Revenue but there's
definitely in a lot of these older
hotels these huge big spaces like
imagine back in the day you've probably
seen these pictures in the 80s of like
people having the big buffet lunch like
all the workers pour out of the building
and they go to the hotel across the
street and they have this big buffet
lunch that's not happening anymore so if
you have a hotel that's bought in the
80s you have to figure out what are
those built in the 80s you have to
figure out what that space becomes and I
don't see a huge business for
different uses or temporary uses or gig
economies or something like that
um you've mentioned a couple times
meetings obviously there's people who
will fly in for an event right and
they'll kind of do whatever that event
conference whatever is there but also
one of the things that I've noticed from
my own behavior and when other people
come to visit is they will be in town
for a conference you know at a
conference hall or or some other event
and they're like hey just meet me in the
hotel lobby yeah but the hotel lobbies
are not built for meetings but they are
very much usually built for uh kind of
bench seating you know like you're
waiting for maybe somebody to go get
something it just is very much like this
is a hotel lobby
is there a way to basically just
repurpose space like that as well for
again it's not a closed area where
you're gonna do a podcast episode or
anything like that but like two people
just want to meet for an hour in the
lobby and feel like hey not everyone
hears my conversation but also I don't
feel like I'm in you know kind of like a
jail cell uh talking to this person like
how do you kind of deal with things like
that well the hotels that you were
describing I think fit in that commodity
Hotel category we're sitting in this
Lobby and it just sucks like you don't
feel inspired there's nowhere good to
sit there's nowhere good to grab a
coffee and you can't have this
conversation
compare that to the one Hotel in South
Beach which is probably the best hotel
in South Beach it's certainly most
successful at Town South Beach that's a
Lobby that you want to be in you want to
after your meeting then have a drink in
that Lobby so I think a these spaces
have to be better designed another thing
though that we're also doing is we're
creating these little
almost imagine like a glass fish bowl in
the lobby and there's a little keypad
you can go there and you can swipe with
your credit card to book that room for
60 minutes so you don't have to call the
hotel and like talk to a salesperson and
go through all this nonsense you guys
can just come in say hey we're gonna
have a little impromptu four-person
meeting there's a TV in there you can
connect your uh Apple computer to it and
knock it out right there and so that's
an example of something that we're doing
in lobbies that otherwise would just be
big vacant Airy spaces or we're getting
rid of a restaurant like
you know if you're in a big city unless
you have a food-driven restaurant with a
great cocktail program like no one's
going to your restaurant your hotel
unless it's really a standalone style
restaurant so get rid of the restaurant
and put in some of these other uses that
you just mentioned yeah I um uh over the
holidays went to Naples for a few days
and a couple of friends and uh my wife
and I and we were staying in a hotel
that there's two things about it that
was pretty interesting one uh in the
lobby they had a gift shop which I was
pretty surprised actually how many
people were in the gift shop right um
but two was there was this big open area
with horrible seating the whole thing
and then they had two restaurants on the
first floor
um and they literally were like across
the little walkway from each other and
one had a kind of a squared off bar
right people were sitting there watching
whatever and on the other side uh I
watched for multiple days people would
go in they would eat breakfast and then
they wouldn't go the rest of the day it
was just closed you couldn't even go
right and so I was sitting there
thinking to myself like man how much
money could they possibly be making off
of uh the meals in the morning and so I
went and I asked and I was like Hey are
people paying like no it's included in
the thing and I was like oh so not only
is the space going unused but actually
they are losing money essentially right
because they people are not going to go
to that uh Hotel simply because they get
the uh food in the morning they're gonna
go because they want the location they
want all these other amenities and so if
you rip that out like what else could
you do there yeah
and build the restaurant that people
want to pay that people are going to
come from the outside to have meetings
in the hotel I think every great City
needs the great hotel where you want to
come and have a coffee and have a
breakfast meeting at
try and make that your hotel and
ultimately that's our goal in what we do
so that we don't have to worry about
giving breakfast away for free and then
having this vacant restaurant sitting
there all day all right talking about
the economics uh if you think of a gas
station they sell a lot of different
things gas is usually where they make a
lot of money yeah right for you all is
it you're making money on the rooms
you're making money on the food and
beverage you're making money on like all
the incidental type stuff that you could
like rent scooters or like whatever
other crazy things they could do the
valet whatever like where do you guys
actually make money and they're like the
true profit centers of a hotel versus
things that uh people may be paying for
but it's actually not what the the
purpose of the hotel or you guys are
excited about yeah the biggest profit
Center typically are the rooms the
second one is going to be food and
beverage but there's a high cost to that
so you want to make sure that you have a
great outlet and a great bar so you can
generate as much revenue as possible
stuff like spas and scooter rentals are
amenities and they really don't make any
money they the key is to maximize the
amount of non-hotel gas that are coming
to your property to use it one thing
that all the hotels in South Beach are
doing now and other places they're
creating these membership clubs which I
think is really interesting because you
can join there's maybe it's seven
thousand dollars a year all that money
is basically going to subsidize the
operations of the hotel so now all these
other things that they want to do has
such a better flow and a better margin
but you can only do that in certain
hotels you can't do a membership club at
a random Courtyard in uh Chattanooga
right it's got to be the cool hotel I
also think part of what you're getting
at
is these hotels are so big and a lot of
hotels that I like staying in now are
small and they have a sense of scale
that really resonate with people and
some of the coolest hotels that I've
been to are ones that it feels like
you're staying at your chicest friends
like pool house or something like that
or it feels like you're at a private
members Club where like the guests are
curated and the people coming in and out
are people that you want to hang out
with again very different from the
commodity stuff yeah which is where we
can generate the extra return if we're
just going to do commodity stuff then
there's no special sauce There we were
talking a little bit before about Barry
starlington part of the reason why he is
so successful is because he knows
numbers better than anyone else but he
understands people's energy and the vibe
and how to generate more Revenue to make
more profit by creating these spaces
that people want to be at they want to
spend money at and they want to stay at
a lot of big institutional Hospitality
investors
are capital allocators and they happen
to be allocating Capital towards hotels
but they really don't have
the soul and the DNA for hotel investing
they could just do it as good they were
doing apartments or industrial or got it
whatever else all right I got a million
questions now so uh it seems like
there's a trend of Brands whether they
are restaurant Brands whether they are
uh car brands whether they are you know
something outside of the hospitality
industry now getting into sometimes it
is uh kind of condos and apartments
other times it appears that they're
starting to try to get into the hotel
business as well
um is that leading to kind of this idea
of like hey if we have brand if we have
a following if we have kind of an
experiential uh component to what we do
and people it really resonates with if
we then get into the hotel game like
maybe they will come and stay here I
don't think like Porsche has a hotel but
I know that they have some residential
buildings that they're building is that
something that you think will become
more of a trend where these Brands will
try to get into the kind of hotel and
Hospitality game or is that like yeah
they're probably gonna stop at the
apartments and they actually won't get
into hotels
I think it's kind of silly out of condos
too like you know in Miami the Missoni
Condo building like who cares there's
Missoni pillows you could just you know
buy those in the store and put them in
your condo what does that actually do to
drive sales I don't know I think in
hotels it's very similar unless there's
some sort of experience that they're
laying layering into that so if you're
creating the Land Rover hotel and there
are these remote outposts where you go
to do off-roading and all these cool
activities there's an amazing company
called 11 experience which was founded
by a former Blackstone guy and it is all
known for kind of Adventure Sports
skiing hiking mountain biking all this
stuff and they have these great lodges
that are all very remote that to me is
very interesting but I think that people
are going to really
shy away from Brands and put a greater
emphasis on like a collection so this is
what our collection stands for but each
property is unique and different in its
own way because when Brands start to get
really powerful everything starts to get
standardized and you start to lose your
soul and identity yeah uh that brings me
to Airbnb which I think there was a
whole multi-year trend of people saying
I'm going to a new city hotels are
stupid I'm gonna stay in an Airbnb that
makes me cool that makes me uh be able
to uh stay somewhere that feels not like
a kind of standardized Hotel
It Feels Like The pendulum's Swinging
back now a little bit and a number of my
friends and even myself like uh Airbnb
you know I've stated enough of them now
like it's you know sometimes amazing
other times like where's the key uh the
internet's slow you know all the
problems that people have had in those
experiences are you guys seeing that
Trend as well in data or kind of uh
anecdotally talking to people where
people are actually saying I do prefer
to stay in a hotel versus Airbnb when I
travel now hey guys what's going on I
hope that you're enjoying this
conversation but I wanted to interrupt
for a quick second and tell you about a
brand new conference that I'm hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center the event is called lyceum Miami
and tickets are completely free for
anyone who wants to come I'm bringing
together many of the most popular guests
from the podcast over the last couple of
years some of the guest speakers that
we've already announced are people like
Vivek ramashwamy from strive asset
management or Delian and Mike Solana
from Founders fund Chris Williamson from
the modern wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez
from contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there alright
let's get back into this conversation
pre-covered everyone in the hospitality
industry was freaking out well the
experts and the economists were freaking
out about
Airbnb and VRBO and this whole Shadow
industry and then it started to get more
regulated but the reality is it's just
additional Supply that's out there but
it's very different I think if people
are looking for a big house sure Airbnb
might be better but if you're a business
person if you're traveling with your
wife a lot of the
conveniences of a hotel cannot be
overlooked to the challenges of Airbnb
and I think Airbnb and the short-term
rental model is completely changing all
those people that wanted to I don't know
like house hack or whatever that
bullshit's called you know during covid
and like make all the side hustle if
they weren't doing it in a way that's
differentiating themselves now they're
stuck with this house it's probably not
earning any income so there's probably
short-term rental 3.0 which is basically
setting up a hotel within your
collection of short-term rentals the
problem with that is is scale I have 200
rooms I can spread all of my costs over
my rooms in one hotel and provide these
great experiences and all these
amenities you just can't do that in an
economic way with one little house or
two little houses so that's a challenge
that I think there's going to be
professional hosts that try and do it
but the margins still aren't going to be
as good as a hotel and you're still not
going to have a bar and you're not going
to have all the fun I have a friend who
saw the tick tock Instagram like
short-term rentals hey I'm gonna buy a
single family home basically and rent it
out on the Airbnb and uh he's pretty
successful in real estate industry and
he said to me he goes oh I know what
those are and I'll
do I dare ask and he was like oh those
are uneducated slumlords and I was like
wait what and he was like no like
literally the houses that they are
getting he's like two things one is
these people don't understand all the
Dynamics of real estate and kind of all
the things you're describing but second
of all is he goes um using slumlords as
this like bombastic term but actually
what they become is like the party house
right somebody is coming in like they
are only there to use it in this very
transactional way and naturally they
will treat it differently than they
would if they were at a hotel or
anywhere else and so it was fascinating
to me to kind of understand as well like
what you do inside of where you're
staying is really uh some way determine
where you're staying 100 and so like if
you go stay at a really nice hotel like
you're probably not [__] around right
you're probably just going to be like
hey I should respect this place like or
they're gonna kick me out versus the
Airbnb you know people obviously do all
kinds of crazy stuff yeah I think you'll
find in luxury hotels there's still
crazy things that go down but what's the
craziest thing
oh well I mean you could just think of
all these rock star parties like that
what's the craziest thing you guys have
dealt with
uh well I mean we've actually had uh you
know I mean we've had like FBI raids and
like you know there's stuff
four-star hotels I mean you have people
coming in that are criminals it's not on
the whole but you know certainly a hotel
so you guys are literally operating a
hotel you guys had the FBI show you're
doing some raid we've had
[Laughter]
um
I don't even know if I can say this
we've had
people that were uh
uh very high up criminals basically stay
at our hotel we didn't know about it you
know
very wealthy and the FBI contacts us
after to basically you know get some
information what were they doing you
know and she we have to be careful and
it's a little awkward but um on the
whole we rarely have problems like at my
level I do not get calls I can't even
remember the last time I got a call from
one of our team members that there was
an issue that they had to tell me about
in a hotel so
compare that to Airbnb that's totally
different yeah what do you guys do from
a marketing standpoint that kind of
helps Drive traffic is it uh it's pretty
amazing hotels are literally stock
they're 10 years behind yeah your world
of technology so things that you would
think happen in Hospitality just don't
and it's really frustrating part of the
issue to that is these big Brands
control a lot of the technology and
they're just slow moving so think of
like an airline think of your
frustrations with an airline similar
issues in a hotel now you can check in
with your phone and do all that kind of
stuff and we have all the door locks you
know can be open with a phone that
stuff's easy but certain things like
guests preferences transferring from
hotel to hotel even for Seasons it's
very tough for them to do that when you
think it'd be really easy for them to
know the last couple of Four Seasons
that you stayed in and what you did
there it's really hard to execute that
so I think that's a huge opportunity
the other
Big Challenge and it's also a challenge
with short-term rentals is pricing so
there are some algorithms but a lot of
the time we have a team of Revenue
managers all their job is is to price
and change the rates on a daily hourly
minute-by-minute basis based on whatever
they're seeing in the property but it's
still a very manual process it's not
done by AI as much as you think it could
be and that's probably going to be
coming but there's definitely a lot of
things that
have improved like for example we have
mobile ordering at all of our hotels so
think of the time you're sitting at the
beach in Miami and you want to order
food but you got to like flag down the
person to come take your order well now
you can just do it on your phone it'll
just get delivered to you from not
ubereats but from our hotel's kitchen
and from the bar so that's an incredible
amenity but a lot of people have tried
to over complicate what guests really
want and a lot of the times the things
that they want are pretty simple like
being able to order on your phone yeah
when you think of these hotels and kind
of building them out is there a number
of days in a year that you're like okay
if we fill this room
22 percent of the time we know that
we've got a kind of break-even point or
it's more than that and the first time
hoteliers actually figured out what
their Break Even was was during covet
when literally all the hotels closed and
slowly business was coming back you
could tell that these hotels were break
even and I think by the way this is
before Debt Service so that's a whole
nother going back to the real estate
side so Breakeven maybe at
40 depending on the type of hotel if it
was a higher end luxury hotel and you
have higher fixed costs it could be 50
or 60 percent which is actually lower
than I would have thought uh in terms of
you basically let's say it's 40 you
could have a room empty sixty percent of
the year and still not lose money now
you're not making money right and
obviously you layer in all the amenities
and all these other things that may
change some of the economics but
to be vacant more than you are filled
and still be in a decent position it's
like a pretty good kind of floor to have
right if you're operating one of these
hotels uh if you don't own the real
estate and you know kind of all the
caveats the more interesting way to look
at it is actually the opposite so at a
certain point in an amazing in a great
Hotel whether it's a three-star hotel
like a home two Suites by Hilton or the
one Hotel in South Beach once their
revenue and occupancy hits a certain
level the flow through what comes down
to your bottom line your net profit at
the end of the day becomes so large
because you don't have to increase your
fixed costs with all of that incremental
income and occupancy that you're
generating so there's some variable
costs that go up like you're gonna have
to have some more higher housekeeping
costs but because your hotel is 100
occupied you're not going to have to
hire 10 new chefs and two new GMS and
that whole thing the system is running
so all that money is Flowing to the
bottom line so if you're in a market
that is hierarchy occupancy typically
the flow through will be better which is
why we tend to focus on these markets
where people want to be you know you
often have
investors particularly in Hospitality
looking to these markets that
sound like a great recovery story and
most of them tend to be in places where
the government is pretty restrictive and
it's cold and you just look at it and
you're like well I don't think that that
many people are going to be there but
and then you go driving around like look
at all these hipsters look at all these
cool coffee shops and tattoo places well
like okay but that population is there
and it's probably not growing
significantly
consequently somewhere like Miami or
Florida or Texas very different so
we try and invest in these markets that
have more occupancy and much more
diversity of demand so what happened
during covid is a lot of these big
hotels their demand only came from
business Travelers so when that dried up
like who's staying in the big Hilton in
Times Square like no one else
Resorts benefited immensely because all
of their business was Leisure and that
kept on coming and now they're just
going to continue to do well because
Group business which is like big
meetings and kind of these boondoggles
that's now starting to come back too so
the places that people want to be it
sounds so simple location location
tends to prove out in real estate and
same with hotels so resorts are
boondoggle profit centers resorts are
awesome so one of my goals for the next
three years is to acquire a never sell
asset a couple people I know own them
it's something sure maybe you sell maybe
you trade in and out of Partners but it
is an iconic asset that you just can't
replace will be examples of ones that
other people own so the one in South
Beach is one A buddy of mine owns a
hotel called Terranea in Rancho Palos
Verdes California the Beverly Hills
Hotel would be an example it's like
iconic Hotel in New York an iconic hotel
that just has such a history and that is
woven into the fabric of people's lives
like when someone says hey meet me here
that says something like you know what
you're gonna get if you go to the Fianna
in Miami Beach like you know the kind of
experience that you're gonna get
how much of the experiences the uh was
it golden gold plated uh Mammoth or
whatever they got out there like things
like that which uh have zero Revenue
producing uh direct you know to the
bottom line uh capabilities but it's
very iconic there's nowhere else I've
ever seen that before like how much of
that stuff uh can you kind of put some
economics or data around to know should
you put that into a location or not
it's good to be a billionaire so
a lot of these never sell assets happen
to be owned by billionaires because it's
a great place to invest your money
you're going to own it over time the
real estate will appreciate over time
you're going to get cash flow you're
going to get tax benefits but then you
can put your gold Mammoth that won't fit
in your house that no one will see in
your hotel and that's an amazing story
because you know the guy that owns that
hotel is not Mr Fianna that was like a
friend a brand guy that he came up with
hey I'm gonna build a whole city in
Miami around my friend I mean talk about
having friends in high places and really
trusting someone else's vision and that
has proven out to be an amazing asset
filled with
gold mammoths and art museums and there
is a lot of
elements in that using that as an
example that probably don't make money
but it adds to the experience so in one
way or another maybe people are paying a
couple thousand dollars a night because
they get to take a picture of that thing
and they get to walk by it every day and
it adds to whatever they're seeking
um when you think about what they're
doing there or other hotels you
mentioned earlier like a coffee shop in
the lobby or whatever do you put those
in there and try to make them profit
centers or are those items hey we need
to be able to cover our costs here but
it's really augmenting the experience
that then we can sell hotel rooms like
how much of this is uh you guys are
breaking out the actual economics and
trying to make everything profitable
um outside of spas or whatever versus
like it's really just get to break even
and then just push more and more people
here to actually rent these rooms we are
trying to make everything profitable
okay so that is the goal we have
investors we raise money we want
everything to be profitable but we also
want it to be a great amenity for guests
because we think the hotel can't Max
maximize its Revenue potential if they
don't have something like this cool
iconic coffee shop yeah I guess a better
way to think about it is like is there a
single p l for the entire like uh hotel
or do you actually break them out into
separate P L's and then you're uh
literally looking at it like should we
shut down the coffee shop because it's
not making enough money that's a great
question so how it works is you have one
summary p l which includes your rooms
your food and beverage your spa you know
your cabana rental all that stuff and
then you have details so each little
Department like that has its own p l got
it so you can look like wow my rooftop
restaurant is whipping it's doing
amazing but my like ground floor
restaurant uh that sucks like I think we
need to reposition that or you might say
hey we're fine
subsidizing this ground floor restaurant
because it's important for the kind of
like look of when you come into the
hotel we want a certain appearance we
want to hold it to a certain standard
the other really cool thing about a
hotel is
food and beverage like restaurant
business is really hard it is really
hard to make money and with a hotel with
all this other revenue streams coming in
you can actually subsidize and pay for
really good talent pay for really good
design in a standalone restaurant that
would never work so for a hotel to have
a good restaurant I think is a great
opportunity for the hotel but it's also
really important for the neighborhood
and the hotel should you know vocalize
that probably more like all the things
they're doing when I think of hotels
that off top my head I can remember that
I know other people would know if I
mentioned them
um there is this word that keeps coming
up unique in my mind yeah and that
uniqueness is actually two different
things but I think they're related one
is the unique brand so when you think of
the Beverly Hills Hotel like you just
when you see it it looks different it it
just you're like okay there's something
here right there's one here in Miami
which I actually don't know if it's been
successful or not but I think it's
called strawberry hotel or something
like that
um no it's called the good time a good
time Hotel okay so like already but in
my mind The Branding is uh very
different right yeah and um then there's
the experience once you're actually in
there and so I think about it as like
you could have a really unique brand and
a shitty experience Nets out probably
negative in terms of the people's
thoughts on the on the hotel
um but I actually don't know if it works
in Reverse like if you don't have a
unique brand but it's really really good
service is that a net positive or net
negative in people's minds when they
leave and it feels like it's obvious
you'd want a really unique brand a
really unique experience they're both
you know knockout factors and so you put
those together and it's like a home run
and you're very successful but if you
had to choose between The Branding
versus the experience which one is more
important the experience the experience
so interesting you're hitting on
something that happens all the time in
the hotel industry you'll read a press
release
and it will say
introducing ex-hotel brand our goal is
to have 10 of these amazing hotels in
these type of cities throughout the
world and we're going to take over the
world with this amazing hotel brand well
you don't even have one like what if
this whole thing sucks like one of the
things that I find so ridiculous in
hospitality is having to launch this big
brand and having nothing to back it up
with so the approach that I think is a
better approach is to create this iconic
Hotel create this experienced hotel and
then use that to leverage creation of a
brand but everyone wants to like raise a
whole bunch of money around a big
concept with no proof and you know they
do this in other Industries too and
there's a huge amount of risk and it
might not go anywhere yeah how does
interest rates start to affect you guys
um and obviously like the macro
environment so we know that it affects
travel and and things like that in
general obviously recessionary periods
people will just spend less going less
vacations all that's pretty very
self-explanatory but when you start to
think of the more nuanced conversation
around fed policy and interest rates you
guys use debt and that's a huge piece of
driving you know out performance here
um is it something where it's pretty
tried and true and you guys are going in
with like these fixed mortgages and not
taking a ton of risk are you guys doing
like interest-only adjustable rate you
know five-year balloon payments like how
does this work and okay all right how
important is things like uh fed interest
rates moving in terms of hotels
specifically so it's actually very
important and I think it's important in
two ways one it's a big opportunity for
us because during covid we raised a fund
and made a tremendous amount of what's
called preferred Equity investments in
deals at that time it wasn't as a result
of rising interest rates but the concept
was the same the cash flow was reduced
the owner needed to hold on to the asset
we could come in and there was an
asymmetry at the time and I think
there's going to be one again between
the amount of risk we were taking
relative to the reward the return that
we were getting
and in a hotel you can get fixed rate
debt or you can get floating rate debt
in our portfolio we have a lot of fixed
rate debt we also have floating rate
debt it is phenomenal to see what has
happened over the past six months
literally like you can have cash flow
that has evaporated because it's all
going to pay interest rates there's ways
that you can hedge it which we've done
and taken advantage of which you never
think those are going to pay and now
we're an environment where those are
actually paying and what are you guys
doing that like what would be an example
so they're as a hedge yeah so there's
something called a rate cap so you
basically buy a financial instrument
that says If the Fed funds rate or sofa
which is the rate that it's measured off
of moves above a certain level then the
counterparty will actually pay you and
if it doesn't then you bought this thing
you paid for it up front and you
theoretically get no value from it and
historically over the past 10 years
that's what happened lenders would
require you to buy this stuff it would
never come into play and you just blow
it now like you're actually getting a
check and recently I had to talk to one
of our investment guys because I'm like
Hey we're in this interest rate cap like
what do we do how do we get the money
like we need to call them and see how it
happened and uh yeah I know that we
didn't think we're gonna get paid but
actually like here's our bank account
yeah like does it come to us or does it
come to the lender and actually you know
in many cases this goes to the lender
which we didn't know so interest rates
are uh
incredibly important the question is
what's going to happen so you get debt
from primarily two or three different
places in the hospitality World
traditional Banks
cmbs
which would be uh mortgage-backed
Securities or maybe a debt fund
debt funds have no problem owning your
asset whether it's a hotel or an
apartment building or Industrial
cmbs
debt which I'll probably never take
again is the worst because you end up
dealing with what's called a servicer in
Kansas who's like a 22 year old kid who
has no experience doesn't care about you
doesn't really care about the asset is
literally just reading the words on the
page and that's how he's making
decisions and in those cases they
probably don't want to take back the
asset so we've seen certain instances
where we've provided preferred Equity to
extend out that loan by two years
compare that to a debt fund they're like
happy to own your house that's their
goal
they say it's not but a lot of the debt
funds that is their goal some of them
it's certainly not so we've known ones
that don't want to take things back and
want to support you and have been
tremendous to work for our banks have
been and our debt funds have been
tremendous to work with there are others
that you can read about that are taking
the stuff back now and
if they actually take over an asset are
they taking it over and trying to
operate it or they just well yeah
they're going to call my management you
know if they take over my friend's Hotel
they're going to call me and have my
management company run the hotel for
them because they don't know what to do
they're going to put an asset manager in
charge they're going to try and make
these decisions But ultimately they're
going to sell it that's really what
they're going to do maybe they'll put in
an improvement plan depending on what
needs to be done but to get back to your
question
over the next year year and a half
there's gonna be a lot of mortgages that
are coming due and interest rates are
higher it means your borrowing power is
less
so you're either gonna have to pay it on
those loans sell your assets or try and
extend them so there's going to be a lot
of opportunity for
we traditionally invest in common Equity
but during covid we did a lot of
preferred Equity so we think there's
going to be a huge opportunity for
preferred Equity particularly with
strategic Partners like us who do this
day in and day out explain to everyone
in terms of uh people who have heard
common and preferred Equity will think
of tech startups but uh although it's a
similar concept explain how that works
exactly with the hotels so typically in
a hotel capital structure you have debt
and you have Equity the equity that
people refer to is common Equity if you
have preferred Equity it comes in
between the debt and the common equity
and the basic premise is that the
preferred Equity has to get paid back
first plus a preferred return before the
common gets any return or some return so
you're taking less risk relative to the
return but you're still an equity player
so you still have some control rights
you're not dead so you can't just force
a
takeover or sale
but what you can do and the way that we
often structure it is we do soft pref so
we don't have to be paid like a mortgage
like Mezzanine Financing we can be paid
through available cash flow because
we're making the bet that ultimately
after two or three years the hotel is
going to be worth more than what we're
currently investing in at that value and
we're going to get paid either along the
way or at the end but you as the comment
holder do not have to pass which is a
huge Stranglehold off their neck that
other forms of financing would require
like Mezzanine Financing or traditional
debt what's the biggest lesson you've
learned in terms of financing the deals
like what are some of the things that
you wish you knew when you first started
don't do cmbs deals would be one because
when stuff goes wrong it's just a pain
even and stuff doesn't go wrong it's
still annoying relationships like with
anything are key so you want to identify
those lenders that can grow with you
what happens a lot is groups start out
with a lender and then they outgrow them
and now they're kind of you know trying
to find a lender that they trust that's
been really important
also
specific terms so
everyone always says well it's never
going to happen but all this stuff
actually does end up happening so you
really want to not just focus on the
interest rate the term who the bank is
but what the specific
terms are in the mechanics of the loan
because when you're operating this deal
and you have to go through 10 different
Hoops maybe to access some cash that's
locked up or to renovate the hotel it
becomes very complicated if you just uh
we'll deal with it when we get to it so
those two things I think have been
probably the most informative for what
we've seen coming out of covid and and
even now and then the most obvious thing
is just to not over leverage because
I've seen too many friends that with
senior financing and Mezzanine Financing
bring their debt all the way up to 80
percent and yeah it becomes tough to
manage what do you guys Target 60 65
percent yeah it seems like the folks
that I know that are kind of the most
experienced and tend to do the best in
real estate that's about where uh their
kind of upper limit of risk is is about
60 65 and you should look at a deal as
if you're not using any debt at all so
on an unlevered return that's often a
metric that we use well that doesn't
make sense because you're always going
to use debt sure but you want to
understand the deal from that basic
notion a lot of people Syndicate deals
in this sort of way where they're like
hey you're going to get five percent of
cash you know for the life of the
investment on the yield basis but at the
end it's going to be a 20 irr the only
way to make that math work
is if at the end there's some massive
Improvement in the valuation that all
has to come at the end one of the things
we like about hospitality is the cash
flow along the way when things are going
well is much higher so sure you want to
have a big exit at the end of the day
and you want to have the asset
appreciate but you're less reliant on
that in in order to hit your ultimate
irr return hurdle or multiple whatever
it may be yeah it's fascinating what
about uh the actual talent that you guys
bring in-house so I'm assuming that you
have kind of a I'll call like a home
office in terms of the actual investment
in acquiring the real estate and brand
building and that type of stuff but
inside of the hotels uh there's
leadership and then you've got kind of
what I would consider or I think most
people would consider like kind of the
service workers across the different
verticals inside of a hotel uh those
types of jobs tend to be hourly they
tend to be very high churned they tend
to be younger people right like all the
things that would make it very hard to
manage a large organ organization how do
you deal with that or what are some
lessons you guys have learned there in
doing that well it starts from the top
so what happened when I founded Dove
Hill which is our investment company in
2011 with my dad
we ended up growing
way faster than we scaled which maybe is
a common story for a lot of
entrepreneurs so at the time my dad had
three hotels now we have 17 so we've
grown a lot in a very quick way and
pre-covered the culture wasn't that
great at the company we had some really
good people but we had some really bad
people so
coming out of covet our goal was to come
out better than how we went in so it
started at the top and we have an
amazing head of people now we do all
this culture and team building stuff we
set priorities we have Monday morning
meetings it's just a totally different
vibe and that filters through to the
property teams but each hotel is like
its own little business
so what I always find fascinating is
some people
don't put enough emphasis in creating
that culture at the property they might
have a great corporate culture but they
don't have the culture of the property
and they hire what's called a general
manager that's the person that runs the
property or managing director
and they don't realize that this person
is in control of a 50 100 million dollar
asset
like this is almost like a CEO so he has
to create an organization
and a culture that people want to be a
part of but there's a big mix of people
like there's a lot of as you said hourly
team members and there's a lot of
smaller amount of salary team members so
in that sense it's it's very different
from Corporate America because you're
dealing with people that maybe don't
speak English as well you're dealing
with people that have completely
different priorities than some of the
senior people but we have events we have
parties we have newsletters engagement
is key and we try and Empower people to
feel good and we want them to feel like
working at our hotel is different from
working somewhere else because churn is
really big and the the biggest challenge
right now hotels are facing is labor
post covid it has just been a disaster
frankly it's improved significantly and
we've been able to get some great talent
but
their
a lot of the The Little Secret in
Hospitality right now is that most of
these hotels by are staffed by staffing
companies
and
essentially they hire workers that the
hotel couldn't hire
and it's not because we don't pay them
enough it's because they don't have the
proper paperwork
and I think what the hospitality
industry is really now lobbying for is
to increase the amount of work permits
and to separate the conversation between
immigration and work permits there are
avenues that we use like J-1 Visa where
we get Hospitality students from other
countries to come in and work at our
hotels and those are phenomenal people
there are people outside of our borders
that want to work here it's figuring out
how to do it in a way where they can pay
taxes and it's done in a legal way and
that's what the hotel lobbying industry
is doing right now it's not for lack of
paying people we've increased wages
massively across
uh in certain positions probably from
the start of covid like take uh room
attendance which is the largest group in
a hotel in some hotels it could have
gone up 20 or 30 percent
um in some cases maybe even more and
you're setting wages competitively
against the other hotels around and wage
is not always a enough to get people in
the doors because there's just not
enough people so let's say you've raised
20 30 percent what does that look like
on an hourly basis one of the things
that I'm fascinated by is
um uh obviously the national minimum
wage uh is sub ten dollars and there's
been a lot of talk about bringing up to
15 an hour but there's a ton of
companies that have already because of
these Dynamics 18 19 20 I think you know
uh McDonald's Amazon like multiple
companies now we're well above that
fifteen dollars and it's always
fascinating to me of like the free
market somehow has accomplished
something that the politicians haven't
been able to yet
um and there's pluses and minus as to
why that happens how it happens like
it's a super complicated topic but what
do you guys think in in terms of
somebody uh who didn't go to school or
Goes to School wants to come work at uh
um one of your guys properties like what
is like the average wage look like you
think it depends so it's Market
dependent but my sister called me the
other day and she's like do you know the
average you know or the minimum wage in
Philadelphia is X I'm like yeah it's
crazy I don't think we have one hotel
that a starting wage is anywhere close
to the minimum wage yeah
it just is not competitive and that
changed and it was like that before
covid but now it's even more extreme so
in a market where the minimum wage might
be ten dollars we could be paying room
attendance 15 16 so 50 percent greater
than what that minimum wage is and is
that's not enough and you guys are nice
people but it's not because you're like
hey let's just pay as much as we
possibly can you're literally saying to
yourself what is the dollar amount to
get people to come apply here that are
good qualified people who can execute
and kind of be part of this company and
you're saying that even when you pay
those wages it is still difficult to
find the best people yeah and in fact
we're paying the staffing companies more
because they've got to get their Vig and
they've got to pay their people so the
cost to us ends up being higher we'd
prefer to pay it direct to someone that
will come so hopefully that transition
will start to happen but we are nowhere
near minimum wage and I would bet that
any
you know above three or four star hotel
is is probably well above the minimum
wage it's also we started to stop
hiring outside of or inside of
hospitality for certain positions so
like traditionally the front desk is
like a total waste they ask you like a
dumb question when you come to the hotel
like oh are you here to check in like of
course I have my suitcase you know I
look like I just got off a plane of
course I'm here to check in you know
that is
what every single front desk agent asks
the person oh can I see your credit card
can I see this it's just so
transactional instead wouldn't it be
great if they said hey Mr pomp I love
your podcast it's awesome to see you
here by the way do you know we have a
podcast room I don't know if you have
anything scheduled but you can actually
do it there oh and by the way like I
need your credit card but to open that
way is so much more interesting but
people have been trained to do that in
the hospitality business so we're trying
to find people that are not in
Hospitality to be some of those
front-facing positions obviously
management you need this deep experience
you can't hire a cook that's never
cooked before
but for some of that stuff we want to
find people that haven't worked for in
hospitality and that holds true for the
corporate level too so we've been hiring
some investment people that might not
have a Hospitality background a lot of
them do a lot of them went to big fancy
Ivy League schools and whatever that's
great but we also want to look at people
with a different perspective our head of
people and culture that we just brought
on to our team has essentially no
Hospitality experience I thought that
was the greatest one of the greatest
attributes about her yeah I am I have a
couple friends that went to Cornell and
yeah that's the big mecca for all these
like hospitalities and people so uh two
of the friends got married on Cornell's
campus yeah so we went and of course you
got to stay in the hotel because they
were talking about it and uh it was
fascinating to uh for those that don't
know Cornell has a uh uh essentially a
hotel on campus that uh they have a
restaurant they got a whole bunch of
stuff but it is run by the students and
that can go one of two ways right either
like it blows you away because they're
young and hungry and they want to do a
great job or whatever uh it also goes
the other way which is like they don't
know what they're doing and whatever and
you see kind of a little bit of both but
it was a pretty cool thing to kind of be
there and literally realize like this is
like a 20 year old kid who is
responsible for the front desk and like
he's gonna figure it out right one way
or another or maybe they fire him I
don't know exactly how it works and
that's where I mean that's the gold
standard in the US and there's European
Hotel schools and our head of
Investments went to Cornell and he went
to European one and just the mentality
oh he double dipped he double dipped and
it's so different like so you're talking
about a 20 year old like checking you in
I think at the European schools the kids
have to wear like a suit and tie to go
to their dining hall it's like a full
fine dining experience so the students
are serving other students but that sort
of old school Hospitality I think in
some ways it'd be great if it would come
back but
Cornell is a tremendous Foundation I
think it's so important though to layer
it with
practical on the ground training I don't
want to say good things about Cornell
because that my friends will their heads
will explode so they probably Cornell is
whatever it's fine
you mentioned that you started the
business with your dad uh he had already
been kind of in the hotel business did
you always want to go into the hotel
business and kind of growing up around
it or was it something that you just
kind of were like ah I'm gonna do this
because there was kind of an opportunity
to uh to jump into it so when I was
younger I would always work these odd
jobs in a hotel my dad is the hardest
worker you'll ever meet and maybe in
some ways it was an opportunity to hang
out with my dad because he was always
working in his hotels and he loved doing
that and I was hanging out with him in
the hotels and and working too but it's
kind of like I don't know if a kid's dad
is a race car driver and he becomes up
and grows up to be a race car driver
it's a similar thing I always knew I
wanted to be in real estate but I always
thought hotels were the most difficult
thing and I had some sort of Insider
knowledge and that could be a real
competitive Advantage if I would have
went into some other
form of real estate I would have done
well but I would have been setting aside
the advantage that I had yeah and now
as we continue to grow we'd like to
invest in other real estate asset
classes but you know anything looks easy
after you've done hotels which is much
better than going the opposite way going
from you know industrial to hotels
completely different yeah
um how do you guys operate together uh I
water and Sun yeah I work with a number
of my brothers and all this stuff so
like how have you guys found is the best
way to work together because I'm sure
there's some amazing moments and then
I'm sure there's some like hey are we
gonna see eye to eye on this thing you
uh nailed it and uh so he won't listen
to this so you can say whatever you want
yeah he won't I mean he it's it's pretty
funny I'll send it to him so he'll
figure it out but his system we'll have
to show him how to use YouTube
um but my dad is just super old school I
mean literally came from nothing worked
his way up in the hotel business
and I think was incredibly proud and
humbled with what he created as he
should be because it was phenomenal to
have three hotels in in a major City
like Philadelphia you know coming from
the streets of queens and when I came
into the business there wasn't any room
for me my dad kind of had a right-hand
guy so if I wanted to find something to
do other than to just be my dad's kid I
had to grow it in a slightly different
way and that's definitely caused some
pain points and and some challenges all
that we've been able to
work through but certain ways that we
were doing things when we were three
hotels just don't work when you're 17
hotels so we had to transition that and
a lot of those we had to learn the hard
way
so for the past couple of years we've
been really focusing on our systems and
our processes and my dad and I actually
went to coaching like we have an
executive coach that primarily works
with me but part of his role is to help
my dad and I work better together and I
credit my dad for
being way more open-minded to this stuff
than I had ever thought and at first
he's gonna like slam his fist down and
say we're not doing this what are you
guys crazy and then he evolves and he
thinks about it and we end up going down
that road and that road and I find that
the path to a decision if my dad and I
have to make it together might be bumpy
it might be very tumultuous but we
always end up landing at a good place
and probably where our minds were both
at at the end of the day there's very
many times with my dad and I'll say okay
we'll agree to disagree he'll probably
you know that might be said but then
he'll end up agreeing with me so it
works out well but it
takes a lot of work as you know you have
to be very intentional with it this is
one of the the weird Dynamics where
people haven't ever been in it before it
kind of feels like what are you guys
talking about but
um uh it's natural to have the
disagreeableness right because uh you
trust the person so much but like not in
uh hey this is my business partner like
this is my son this is my dad it's my
brother's whatever
um and what I found is that like part of
that process of just like knocking heads
over and over and over again uh is
because you can be so honest with each
other like you will definitely say
things to your brother your dad your son
whatever that you would not say to
anyone else uh Sometimes good sometimes
not
um but that disagreeableness almost is
kind of like the iterations that get you
to a better decision and so I've noticed
that like some of the decisions that
we've made literally is the same thing
like on first pass it's like oh this is
gonna be a blowout fight and then what
you realize is when we get to the end
you're like I would not have made this
decision unilaterally they would not
have made this decision unilaterally but
we ended up here because we kind of had
to like fight it out a little bit and be
because of that process we actually end
up in a better place and so it almost
makes you like kind of wish that every
business that you were an investor in
had some Dynamic like that now it needs
to be respectful it has to have the
long-term Trust of like you know you're
gonna go away and so I always tell my
brothers like dude we can be as mad at
each other as we want we still got to be
brothers 100 right and so like we will
survive this uh even if it takes a
little while but that's very Admiral
because I think
oftentimes today and you hear about it
people
you know just pull the rip cord with
their family and they're fine with not
speaking to a family member or blowing
up a whole relationship over something
that happened in business but if you
were both coming from the place where
our end state is not just walking away
and never speaking to each other that we
need to find a solution tension that
you're describing often results
in better decisions and more thoughtful
decisions and by the way like it's
sometimes good to have a speed bump
because it might make you as the one
pushing something more thoughtful more
analytical about whatever it is you're
doing and maybe you have to make a
little presentation or put some more
work into it and maybe the first path
you thought you were going down is not
where you end up it's kind of close but
it ends up being better because of that
tension and dispute so it's a uh benefit
and a curse all at the same time which
not many people know so you get your dad
you've got you I don't do you have uh
kids
uh I have kids okay they are you know
I'm you know I don't know how old are
you we look like the same age right like
my kids are five and eight okay if they
want to work in the business grade I
have a Powerhouse wife who runs her own
Mega business so maybe they go into that
maybe they go into my business but I
definitely want to build something
that's enduring to last and that could
survive with my kids coming in could
survive without them but
what are you doing with them to prepare
them and this is uh fascinating to me
because the the joke and especially in
like the uh Asset Management world right
is like uh the first generation starts
with the second generation skills and
the third generation gives it all back
yeah right and like royally screws it up
uh and there's all kinds of theories as
to why this happens but like are you
guys uh obviously I don't think you're
like pushing your kid and you're like
you know get into the hotel right now
and like learn yeah but are there
certain things that you all are trying
to do with your kids to kind of just
prepare them for what I would think is
just like a different life right if they
run any business whether it's the
businesses that you guys are in or or
different ones it seems like you need a
different skill set and a different kind
of approach and mindset is there
anything that you guys uh intentionally
do there kids are sponges so they're
gonna absorb everything from their
parents The Good the Bad and the Ugly
and
if you have a mindset where you're
focusing on your family and your kids
and you're finding a way to work at the
same time then I think they're going to
see that they also know what business
I'm in they know what business my wife's
in they like going to Hotel so now it's
basically like bringing them to a
construction site or bringing them to a
hotel opening or even better taking them
on a great vacation and instilling that
passion for hospitality and travel
through seeing these great hotels and
really opening their mind to travel and
being more worldly but they're five and
eight so it's just a totally different
conversation from some friends of mine
who have kids that are
in their late 20s starting to look at
coming into the business and maybe
that's a third generation business and
you have to be really thoughtful about
it because if you have multiple brothers
and you both own a piece of the business
well like how do you deal with that
finally Dynamic of one kid that just
wants to be a shareholder one kid that
wants to work in the business so I think
you really have to be thoughtful about
it and maybe it's not so much the third
generation that screws it up maybe it's
the first and second generation that
didn't really set the guard rails for
that third one to succeed so that's
something that I think about we have
plenty of years to
deal with it but even the transition
between my father and I that has to be
very thoughtful as well so it's first to
second to third equally along the way is
something that we we definitely think
about because you don't want
to be out in a situation where you have
outside shareholders that are making
decisions and hurting the business in
some cases outside shareholders that
can't say anything are great because you
don't buy them out and they're getting
dividends and it's perfect so you really
have to think about what structure will
work best but right now I'm
hanging with the kids and trying to be
be there all the time be flexible I
think that's a great way to approach
life where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about the business so I started getting
really intentional on Twitter which I
noticed that Jay wurzak so I guess you
can find me there
um Jake warzac.com we'll probably have
some links to our companies ways to
invest we've raised over 100 million
dollars from high net worth investors
we've partnered with a bunch of private
institutions and I am fascinated with
social media and the power of the
internet because I think that
what you put out you get back 10 times
through new relationships new friends
maybe New Deals New Opportunities new
employees and the opportunities are
endless so that's really why you see me
out there but I think you're doing a
great job and you've got a very unique
perspective I think right obviously real
estate stuff is different than all the
tech stuff but also kind of the hotels
and the way that you present the
information I think people really are
enjoying so don't stop tweeting I won't
um but no thank you so much for your
time I've learned a ton today I think a
lot of other people will really enjoy
this conversation will definitely do it
again in the future thank you you're the
man you're a master